quantum entanglement ทำให้อนุภาคสามารถเชื่อมโยงกันได้โดยไม่สนใจระยะห่างระหว่างพวกมัน ซึ่งฟังดูขัดกับสัญชาตญาณมากเลย
จนแม้แต่ Einstein ยังไม่เชื่อว่ามันเป็นเรื่องจริง ในตอนวันนี้ของ Qiskit in the Classroom เราจะมาพูดถึงว่า Bell's
theorem พิสูจน์ว่า Einstein
คิดผิดยังไง ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the Classroom ในซีรีส์นี้เราจะใช้ Qiskit สำรวจแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่มักจะ
ปรากฏในคอร์สที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ Quantum Computing แต่ละวิดีโอยังมี interactive module ให้ด้วย
ลิงก์อยู่ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมเช็กดูนะ ในวิดีโอ quantum coins เราพูดถึงว่าการวัด
quantum superposition นั้นเป็นกระบวนการที่มีความน่าจะเป็นโดยธรรมชาติ เหมือนการโยนเหรียญในบางแง่ แต่เราจะรู้ได้ยังไง
ว่ามันเป็นอย่างนั้น เป็นไปได้ไหมที่อนุภาค quantum ซ่อนผลลัพธ์ที่กำหนดไว้ล่วงหน้าของการวัด แต่เราไม่สามารถ
รับข้อมูลนี้ไปใส่ในทฤษฎีได้ ในยุคแรกของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม คำถามนี้เป็นหัวข้อ
ที่ถกเถียงกันอย่างดุเดือด โดยมีสองกลุ่มหลัก กลุ่มหนึ่งคือ Einstein ที่เชื่อว่ากลศาสตร์ควอนตัมยังไม่สมบูรณ์
นั่นคือมันขาดตัวแปรบางตัวที่จำเป็นต้องมีเพื่ออธิบายระบบได้อย่างครบถ้วน Einstein คิดว่า
ตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่พวกนี้ ถ้าหาเจอ จะช่วยแก้ปัญหาที่ดูเหมือนขัดแย้งและเป็นไปตามความน่าจะเป็น
ของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมได้ ส่วนอีกกลุ่มหนึ่งคือ Max Born ซึ่ง Born โต้แย้งว่า
การอธิบายแบบความน่าจะเป็นที่กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมให้มานั้นคือทุกสิ่งที่ธรรมชาติระบุไว้ กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่งคือ
ไม่ใช่แค่ว่าเราไม่รู้สถานะของอนุภาคก่อนวัด แต่อนุภาคไม่มีสถานะที่แน่นอน
ก่อนที่จะถูกวัด หลายทศวรรษที่ผ่านมาหลายคนคิดว่าความขัดแย้งนี้เป็นคำถามเชิงปรัชญาที่อาจจะ
ไม่มีวันถูกแก้ไขได้ ท้ายที่สุดแล้ว เพื่อจะเรียนรู้อะไรสักอย่างเกี่ยวกับระบบเราต้องวัดมัน แล้วเราจะเรียนรู้
อะไรเกี่ยวกับธรรมชาติของสถานะก่อนที่จะวัดมันได้ยังไง แล้วในปี 1964 นักฟิสิกส์
John Bell ก็หาทางออกได้ ในบทความของเขา Bell ศึกษาความสัมพันธ์ทางสถิติระหว่างการวัดคู่ของ
อนุภาคที่ entangle กัน ถ้าก่อนการวัด สถานะของอนุภาคถูกกำหนดโดยตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่ที่ไม่รู้จัก
Bell ก็พบว่าความสัมพันธ์ของพวกมันมีขีดจำกัดสูงสุด ในทางกลับกัน เมื่อเขาคำนวณ
ความสัมพันธ์ที่กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมทำนายไว้ เขาพบว่ามันละเมิดขีดจำกัดนี้ ดังนั้นเขาจึงหาทางที่จะ
แยกแยะระหว่างมุมมองของ Einstein และ Born ได้อย่างชัดเจน สิ่งที่เหลือก็แค่ทำการทดลองจริง
เพื่อทดสอบความสัมพันธ์เหล่านี้กับอนุภาคจริง เพื่อดูว่าพวกมันเชื่อฟังสถิติตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่หรือ
ละเมิดกฎนั้น การทดสอบเหล่านี้ถูกดำเนินการด้วยความแม่นยำและความซับซ้อนที่เพิ่มขึ้น
ตลอดหลายปีที่ผ่านมา และเป็นการทดลองที่สำคัญที่สุดอย่างหนึ่งของฟิสิกส์สมัยใหม่ มันสร้างผลกระทบมากจน
ทำให้นักฟิสิกส์สามคนได้รางวัล Nobel ในปี 2022 แต่ทุกวันนี้ใครก็สามารถทำ
Bell test ได้ สิ่งที่ต้องการก็แค่ความรู้เรื่อง Qiskit และการเข้าถึงคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมของ IBM ในวิดีโอนี้ฉันจะ
พาคุณผ่านตรรกะของ Bell's inequality แล้วฉันจะแสดงให้เห็นว่าเราสามารถทดสอบคำทำนายของ Bell บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม IBM
ได้ยังไง Bell's inequality เกี่ยวข้องกับการวัดและชั้นของตรรกะหลายอย่าง และมันอาจ
ยากนิดนึงที่จะตาม แต่เราจะค่อยๆ ผ่านไปทีละขั้น และในตอนท้ายมันคุ้มค่าแน่ๆ เราจะแสดงให้เห็นว่า
entanglement มีอยู่จริงและ Einstein คิดผิด ซึ่งไม่ใช่สิ่งที่คนหลายคนจะบอกได้ว่าตัวเองทำมาแล้ว ดังนั้นนี่คือ
สิ่งที่ Bell เสนอ สมมติว่าคุณมีวิธีสร้างสำเนาของคู่อนุภาคที่ entangle กันหลายๆ ชุด ในทางกายภาพ
คู่เหล่านี้สามารถถูกสร้างได้ผ่านกระบวนการสลายตัวที่อนุภาคหนึ่งแตกออกเป็นสอง ถ้าดูวิดีโอเรื่อง
การทดลอง Stern-Gerlach คุณจะรู้ว่าอนุภาคมีโมเมนตัมเชิงมุมที่แท้จริงที่เรียกว่า
spin สมมติว่าอนุภาค spin ศูนย์ตัวหนึ่งสลายตัวเป็นอนุภาค spin 1/2 สองตัว
แล้วแต่ละอนุภาค spin 1/2 สามารถถูกวัดให้มี spin บวก 1/2 หรือลบ
1/2 ซึ่งเรียกอีกอย่างว่า spin up หรือ spin down แต่เนื่องจากพวกมันสลายตัวมาจากอนุภาค spin ศูนย์ สองตัวนั้นต้องรวมกัน
ให้มี spin รวมเป็นศูนย์ด้วย ดังนั้นถ้าตัวหนึ่งถูกวัดว่าเป็น up อีกตัวต้องเป็น
down และในทางกลับกัน อนุภาคเหล่านี้ก่อเป็นคู่ที่ entangle กันที่หน้าตาเป็นแบบนี้
ดังนั้นถ้าตัวหนึ่งถูกวัดว่าเป็น up อีกตัวก็จะเป็น down และในทางกลับกัน สมมติว่าอนุภาคหนึ่งบินไปทางซ้ายหรือ
ทิศทางลบ X ที่นักวิจัยที่เราจะเรียกว่า Lucas วัด
spin ของมัน แล้วอนุภาคสองก็บินไปทางขวาในทำนองเดียวกัน
ที่ Rihanna อีกคนสามารถวัด spin นั้นได้ Lucas และ Rihanna สามารถ
หมุนอุปกรณ์วัดของตัวเองอย่างอิสระเพื่อเลือกวัด spin ของอนุภาคของตัวเองในทิศทางใดก็ได้
ที่ตั้งฉากกับทิศทางการเคลื่อนที่ของอนุภาค ถ้าเราส่งสำเนาของสถานะที่ entangle กันหลายๆ ชุดให้ Lucas
และ Rihanna พวกเขาสามารถรวบรวมสถิติการวัดได้ ถ้าพวกเขาวัดตามแกนเดียวกันเสมอ สถิติเหล่านี้จะไม่
น่าสนใจมากนัก ทุกครั้งที่คนหนึ่งวัดได้ spin up อีกคนก็วัดได้ spin down และทุกครั้งที่คนหนึ่งวัดได้ spin
forward อีกคนก็วัดได้ spin backward และอื่นๆ แต่ถ้านักวิจัยทั้งสองวัดตามแกนต่างกัน เราอาจพบ
สิ่งที่น่าสนใจกว่านั้น ให้ Lucas และ Rihanna มีสามแกนในการ
วัด เราจะเรียกแกนเหล่านี้ว่า a, b และ c และแต่ละแกนห่างกัน
120 องศา คำถามที่เราจะถามในการทดลองนี้คือ ถ้า Lucas และ Rihanna อิสระที่จะวัดตามแกนใดก็ได้ในสามแกน
พวกเขาจะได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกันบ่อยแค่ไหน ชัดเจนว่าถ้า Lucas และ Rihanna วัดตามแกนเดียวกัน
เช่น แกน a พวกเขาจะไม่มีทางได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกัน เนื่องจากอนุภาคต้องรวมกันให้มี spin เป็นศูนย์ แต่เมื่อพวกเขาเลือก
แกนต่างกัน การวัดของพวกเขาจะสัมพันธ์กันยังไง ถ้าเป็นไปได้เลย ตาม Einstein แล้ว การอธิบาย quantum
mechanical ของสถานะอนุภาคนั้นไม่สมบูรณ์ เขาคิดว่าต้องมีตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่ที่
กำหนดผลลัพธ์ของการวัด spin ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดล่วงหน้า เนื่องจากหากไม่มีสิ่งนั้น อนุภาคที่ entangle กันจะต้อง
สื่อสารผลลัพธ์การวัดถึงกันทันทีในทันที ถ้าอันหนึ่งถูกวัดว่าเป็น up
ตรงนี้ อีกอันก็ต้องรู้ทันทีว่าต้องเป็น down ตรงนั้น
ตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่เหล่านี้อาจเป็นชุดคำสั่งที่ซับซ้อนสำหรับผลลัพธ์ของการทดลอง แต่ประเด็นก็คือ
สถานะ spin ของแต่ละอนุภาคถูกกำหนดแยกกัน ดังนั้นจึงไม่จำเป็นต้องสื่อสารกัน
ในเชิงการทดลอง นั่นหมายความว่าการวัดที่ Lucas ทำจะไม่มีผลต่ออนุภาคของ Rihanna และในทางกลับกัน
ซึ่งอาจกำหนดขีดจำกัดบางอย่างของความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างการวัดทั้งสอง แต่ตาม Born สถานะนี้
คือทั้งหมดที่สามารถพูดถึงคู่อนุภาคก่อนการวัดได้ ดังนั้นการวัดอนุภาคหนึ่ง
จะส่งผลต่อผลลัพธ์ของการวัดอีกอนุภาคหนึ่ง สิ่งนี้อาจมีนัยที่แตกต่างกันสำหรับความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างการวัด มาดูกันว่าแต่ละ
ทฤษฎีมีผลต่อความสัมพันธ์เหล่านี้ยังไง ในการปฏิบัติตามตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่จะมีชุดคำสั่งลับก่อน
การวัดที่กำหนดสิ่งที่ Lucas จะวัดตามแต่ละแกนในสามแกนไว้ล่วงหน้าแล้ว ตัวอย่างเช่น
คำสั่งเหล่านี้อาจเป็นบวกถ้า Lucas วัดตามแกน a
บวกถ้าเขาวัดตาม B และลบถ้าเขาวัดตาม c เราสามารถ
เขียนสิ่งนี้ว่า บวก a บวก b และลบ c แล้วอนุภาคของ Rihanna
ก็จะต้องมีตัวแปร ลบ a ลบ b และบวก c เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่า spin รวม
ตามทิศทางใดทิศทางหนึ่งเป็นศูนย์
มีชุดคำสั่งที่เป็นไปได้แปดชุดที่ตอบสนองเงื่อนไข spin เป็นศูนย์นี้ ดังนั้นทุกครั้งที่คู่อนุภาคใหม่
ถูกส่งให้ Lucas และ Rihanna มันอาจมีชุดคำสั่งใดชุดหนึ่งจากแปดชุดนี้ ดังนั้นเราต้องการ
หาคำตอบว่า โดยสมมติว่าอนุภาคมีชุดคำสั่งลับชุดหนึ่งที่ให้ไว้ในตาราง และ
สมมติว่า Lucas และ Rihanna ต่างเลือกอย่างอิสระว่าจะวัดตามแกนไหนในสามแกน ความน่าจะเป็นที่
พวกเขาทั้งสองวัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกันคือเท่าไหร่ ถ้าคำสั่งเป็นอย่างที่ระบุไว้ในแถวที่ 1 หรือ
8 ความน่าจะเป็นนี้ก็เป็นศูนย์อย่างชัดเจน เนื่องจากอนุภาคทั้งสองจะมีเครื่องหมายตรงข้ามกันโดยไม่สนใจแกนการวัด
แต่แล้วคำสั่งในแถวที่สองล่ะ พวกเขาจะวัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกันถ้า
Rihanna วัดตาม c และ Lucas วัดตาม a หรือ b หรือถ้า Lucas
วัดตาม c และ Rihanna วัดตาม A หรือ B นั่นคือสี่ในเก้า
ของชุดการวัดที่เป็นไปได้ที่จะให้ Lucas และ Rihanna ได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกัน ถ้าเราทำแบบนี้กับ
แต่ละชุดคำสั่ง คุณจะเห็นว่าแถวที่ 3 ถึง 7 ก็ให้ความน่าจะเป็น 4/9 เหมือนกัน ซึ่งหมายความว่าถ้า
Einstein พูดถูกและตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่เหล่านี้กำหนดผลลัพธ์การวัดล่วงหน้า ไม่มีทางที่ Lucas
และ Rihanna จะวัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกันด้วยความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า 4/9 นี่คือ Bell inequality ที่ P น้อยกว่า
หรือเท่ากับ 4/9 และอย่างที่เราจะแสดง อนุภาคที่ entangle กันละเมิดสิ่งนี้ ดังนั้นเพื่อ
ดูว่ากลศาสตร์ควอนตัมทำนายอะไร สมมติว่า Lucas วัดตาม a สองสิ่งที่สามารถเกิดขึ้นได้คือเขาวัดได้ spin up ดังนั้น
Rihanna จะวัดได้ spin down ตาม a หรือเขาวัดได้ spin down และ Rihanna จะวัดได้ spin up ตาม a แต่เรา
ต้องการความน่าจะเป็นที่ Rihanna วัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกับ Lucas ตามแกนใดก็ได้ที่เธอเลือก ไม่ใช่แค่ a ถ้า
เธอวัดตาม B หรือ C มันจะซับซ้อนขึ้นนิดหน่อย ปรากฎว่า
ถ้าคุณรู้ว่า Rihanna จะวัดอะไรด้วยความแน่ใจ 100% ตามทิศทางหนึ่ง คุณสามารถคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นที่
เธอจะวัดได้ up หรือ down ตามแกนอื่นๆ ได้ด้วยเรขาคณิตเล็กน้อย
ถ้าสถานะของคุณวัดได้ spin up ตามแกนหนึ่งเสมอ ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะวัดได้ spin up ตามแกนอื่น
จะเท่ากับกำลังสองของโคไซน์ของครึ่งหนึ่งของมุมระหว่างสองแกน มันซับซ้อนนิดหน่อย แต่
ฉันจะแสดงให้เห็นว่าหมายความว่าอะไร ถ้า Lucas วัดได้ spin up ตาม a เรารู้ด้วยความแน่ใจ 100% ว่า Rihanna จะวัดได้
spin down ถ้าเธอวัดตาม a ดังนั้นเราสามารถแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์
แบบนี้ ในกรณีนี้ มุมระหว่างเวกเตอร์นี้กับแกนการวัดอีกสองแกน B และ C ต่างก็
60 องศา ดังนั้นครึ่งหนึ่งของนั้นคือ 30 องศา และโคไซน์ของ
30 แสดงอยู่นี่ โคไซน์กำลังสองของ
30 องศา เท่ากับ 3/4 แล้วถ้า Lucas วัดได้ spin down
ตาม a เรารู้ว่า Rihanna จะวัดได้ spin up ตาม a ดังนั้นเราสามารถวาดเวกเตอร์อีกอันตรงนี้
เวกเตอร์นี้ที่แทนความรู้นี้ห่างจากแกนอีกสองแกน B
และ C 120 องศา ดังนั้นเราสามารถใช้เทคนิคเรขาคณิตเดียวกัน แต่คราวนี้จะได้โคไซน์ของ
60 องศา ดังนั้นโคไซน์กำลังสองของ
60 องศา เท่ากับ 1/4 เนื่องจาก Lucas มีโอกาสเท่ากันที่จะ
วัดได้ spin up และ spin down ตาม a เราต้องหาค่าเฉลี่ยของความน่าจะเป็นทั้งสองของ Rihanna เราจะได้ค่า
ความน่าจะเป็นสุดท้ายที่ Rihanna จะวัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกับ Lucas คือ 1/2 ดังนั้น P
เท่ากับ 1/2 ซึ่งมากกว่า 4/9 ดังนั้น Bell's inequality ถูกละเมิด
นั่นหมายความว่าตราบใดที่กฎของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมยังคงอยู่ ตัวแปรที่ซ่อนอยู่เป็นไปไม่ได้ ตอนนี้เราสามารถใช้ Qiskit และ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม IBM เพื่อทดสอบ Bell inequality ด้วยการวัดควอนตัมจริงๆ เราสามารถ map สถานะ spin up และ
spin down ของอนุภาคของ Lucas และ Rihanna ไปยังสถานะ zero และ one ของ qubit ในคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เราจะ
ใช้สอง qubit อันหนึ่งแทนอนุภาคของ Lucas และอีกอันของ Rihanna และ entangle พวกมันด้วย quantum circuit นี้
ดังนั้น qubit ทั้งสองแทนด้วยเส้นสอง q0 และ q1 และการรวมกัน
ของ X, Hadamard และ C-NOT gate จะสร้างสถานะ entangle เดียวกันที่เราได้ระหว่างอนุภาคของ Lucas และ Rihanna ตอนนี้เรา
ต้องวัดแต่ละ qubit เราจะตั้งการวัดของ Lucas ให้ตาม a ซึ่งเราจะบอกว่าเป็นแกน Z แล้วการวัดของ Rihanna
สามารถตาม a, b หรือ c ดังนั้นเราจะต้องการสาม circuit แยกกันสำหรับแต่ละสามกรณีนี้ แต่ใน
วิดีโอนี้เราจะทำแค่อันเดียว คุณสามารถไปที่ module ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายสำหรับเรื่องทั้งหมดได้ ถ้า Rihanna วัดตาม
B แล้ว circuit ของเราจะหน้าตาแบบนี้ โดยที่ RY คือการหมุน 120 องศา เพื่อเปลี่ยน
แกนการวัดของ Rihanna เราสามารถใช้ Qiskit Primitive sampler เพื่อรันการทดลองนี้หลายครั้งและรวบรวม
สถิติจากการวัดที่ได้ สองคอลัมน์ 00 และ 11 แทนช่วงเวลาที่ Lucas และ
Rihanna วัดได้เครื่องหมายเดียวกัน ซึ่งนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราต้องการ ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นที่จะวัดอนุภาคทั้งสองให้มี
เครื่องหมายเดียวกันใกล้เคียงกับ 1/2 มาก สิ่งนี้ละเมิด Bell's inequality ซึ่งหมายความว่า
อนุภาคทั้งสอง entangle กันอยู่ แต่ละตัวดูเหมือนจะรู้ผลการวัดของอีกตัวอย่างทันทีทันใด
ยังคงมีความเห็นที่ไม่ตรงกันว่าจะตีความ
entanglement นี้ยังไง และเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อคุณวัดสถานะที่ entangle กัน แต่คำถามเหล่านั้นเป็นเรื่องปรัชญามากกว่า
ทฤษฎีนี้ค่อนข้างปฏิเสธไม่ได้ในตอนนี้ entanglement มีอยู่จริงแน่ๆ และเรารู้สิ่งนี้ต้องขอบคุณ Bell
inequality ของเขา และนักฟิสิกส์มากมายที่ทำการทดลองเพื่อทดสอบมัน ถ้าอยากอยู่ในกลุ่ม
นักฟิสิกส์เหล่านั้นและทำ Bell test ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมของตัวเอง อย่าลืมไปที่ module Bell's inequality
ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบาย ขอบคุณที่ดู แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า